[Musique]
l'hebdo politique bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue dans l'hebdo politique votre
rendez vous politique du dimanche soir
sur radio sensations diffuses et aussi
sur tv5 18 mon invité ce soir pour
l'épisode 206 et ghislaine ce n'est
[Musique]
les politiques
ghislaine sonné bonsoir tout le soir
vous êtes la présidente du pôle
écologiste à la région ile de france
après 17 ans carrière dans le marketing
et la gestion de projets vous êtes entré
en politique en 2008 vous êtes devenu
alors maire de votre village des
vêtements dans les yvelines vous avez
ensuite rejoint europe écologie les
verts en 2009 et lui ensuite en 2010
conseillère régionale vous avez été
réélu à ce poste récemment en 2020 via
la liste d'union de la gauche menée par
julien bayou vous êtes désormais la
présidente du pôle écologiste à la
région ile de france pourquoi est ce que
vous aviez décidé en 2009 de rejoindre
le parti europe ecologie les verts a
alors c'est une c'était mon histoire
mais en fait en 2008 j'ai été élu maire
d'une petite commune où vous l'avez cité
avec mon sens aucune expérience en fait
ans avait été vraiment une envie de
faire bouger les choses et en tout cas
de m'engager et et à l'époque il y avait
un grand projet inutile dans les
yvelines qui étaient des circuits de f1
à flins un circuit de course automobile
est en fait je m'étais immédiatement
engagées contre et du coup les
écologistes sont venus me voir on a
discuté et voilà c'est au travers de
deux de cet échange que j'ai décidé de
les de les rejoindre j'avais besoin et
il faut le dire des partis politiques on
est critique beaucoup et moi n'ayant pas
d'expérience et étant élu maire j'avais
besoin d'eux et bien de deux
d'accompagnement réformation et j'ai
trouvé vraiment voilà le parti dans
lesquels j'ai pu m'épanouir le sentier
le mieux en 2017 pour les
présidentielles yannick jadot était le
candidat des verts il s'était rangé
derrière benoît hamon depuis
lv a profité de l'affaiblissement du
parti socialiste 13 % aux européennes en
2019 la conquête de grandes villes aux
municipales en 2020 lyon bordeaux
strasbourg entre autres puis enfin les
régionales avec quelques coalition
victorieuse vous qui êtes dans ce parti
depuis 2019 vous sentez une réelle
dynamique ces dernières années depuis
2009 oui oui il ya une vraie dynamique
et je ne sais pas si on profite de
l'affaiblissement du ps plus que
finalement nous sommes vraiment sur sur
les sujets qui intéressent les
françaises et les français faire on voit
bien que la question du réchauffement
climatique la question environnementale
la question de la biodiversité sont des
sujets qui inquiètent les françaises et
les français et je crois que c'est
surtout ça qui fait qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes dans cette dans cette dynamique
là l'écologie vous l'avez dit est
devenue un thème majeur dans le débat
politique ces dernières années beaucoup
se revendiquent écologistes même à
droite parce que l'écologie et les
valeurs de droite sont elles compatibles
aussi moi moi je crois que là lol le
libéralisme la concurrence as tu vas là
la recherche de la productivité de la
compétitivité a abandonné pose problème
c'est à dire que on sait que la terre a
des limites si la droite
avait avait une capacité réellement
régler les problématiques
environnementales
aujourd'hui je pense nous n'en serions
pas là
on voit bien enfin moi je le vois je le
vis tous les jours la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse
effectivement tient un discours très
très écolo en tout cas montre une
volonté 2 mais dans les faits quand on
regarde les politiques elle met en place
à la région ile de france en fait si
elle elle va effectivement porté
quelques actions sur sur la question par
exemple d'ouverture de rachat d'espèces
des espaces par nos naturel et bien en
fait dans les faits elle continue en
fait à développer un modèle qui tourne
autour des énergies fossiles qui tourne
autour d'une assiette mans climatique et
on est bien loin des des politiques
publiques à mettre en oeuvre dès
aujourd'hui pour régler la question du
réchauffement climatique pour choisir
votre candidat europe ecologie les verts
a choisi de lancer la primaire
écologiste ouverte à tous cette dernière
a réuni 106 mille votants au premier
tour et 104 milles au second tour c'est
un chiffre qui vous satisfait
à l'échelle de la population française
je ne peux pas dire que ce soit
extraordinaire ceci dit moi je suis très
fier du processus que nous avons que
nous avons porté c'est vraiment un
processus démocratique on va être
quasiment le seul parti à faire
réellement une primaire c'est à dire
laisser le choix l'ensemble des
françaises et des français de pouvoir
faire le choix d'un candidat pour pour
l'écologie
jeux jeux
ont regardé des dvd des chiffres et des
militants europe ecologie les verts et
du pôle écologiste 1 puisque nous avons
rassemblé un certain nombre de parties
le le résultat est pas est pas si
mauvais on a senti quand même que
quelque chose se se produisait mais
c'est vrai que le temps politique là la
façon dont aujourd'hui les
présidentielles qui sont quand même
dans six mois alors que il ya très très
peu finalement deux candidats définitif
je dirais déclaré en fait il était il
était difficile de mobiliser sur sûr à
ce moment de la campagne or il me
semblait que nous étions nous dans le
bon timing et moi j'ai l'impression que
ce sont les autres partis politiques qui
sont vraiment très en retard 13 ans de
ça et je ne vois pas comment ils vont
pouvoir vraiment et labouré co élaborés
co-construire en fait alors leur projet
et c'est une vraie inquiétude en fait on
sent bien que les françaises et les
français en fait ils ont marre de parler
des des élections on a l'impression
qu'il n'y a que ça or c'est quand même
de l'art et venir dont on parle dans ces
présidentielles qu'avez vous pensé des
débats organisés lors de cette primaire
écologiste plusieurs visions du pôle
écologiste ont pu s'exprimer qu'avez
vous retenu de ces échanges et moi ce
que j'ai trouvé très intéressant c'est
que les les les cinq candidats qui
étaient qui étaient présents défendez un
programme commun c'est à dire que nous
nous avons vraiment alors beaucoup de
débats d'ailleurs nous a beaucoup
critiqué dans la partie immature tous
entrain de mai mais en fait on a
vraiment un socle commun très très fort
et que ce soit en l'occurrence on a vu
avec feu est levé mais également avec
génération écologie par exemple avec
avec delphine batho il ya vraiment
quelque chose qui nous qui nous
rassemble et donc moi ce que je trouvais
intéressant c'est c'est finalement de
voir que derrière des personnalités en
fait d'aider façon de faire de la
politique des façons de voir les choses
et bien en fait on voyait bien que que
ce programme se déclinait de manière de
manière différente avec des des
priorités ou
en tout cas exprimé de manière
voyez différentes c'est cela et moi je
trouvais ça très très intéressant au
fait yannick jadot a ensuite été désigné
candidat ancien militant de greenpeace
et membre d'europe écologie les verts
depuis 1999 il a le meilleur profil pour
mener cette campagne moi je pense que
oui il ay là il a le profil pour mener
cette campagne parce que c'est face et
un député européen ça fait trois mandats
qu'il est qui est là bas c'est quelqu'un
qui sait qui s'est négociée qui sait
trouver les consensus
et nous on sait chez les écologistes
qu'il ya une urgence donc honda on a une
forme de volonté de radicalité mais on
sait que la radicalité depuis que l'on
défend l'écologie on sait que la
radicalité en fait inquiète
fait peur les françaises et les français
mais comme beaucoup de 2 du main
voilà n'aime pas n'aime pas le
changement et je pense que justement
c'est quelqu'un qui peut qui peut
apaiser qui peut convaincre qu'il peut
faire de la pédagogie est en tout cas il
dégage suffisamment de charisme pour
qu'on puisse lui faire confiance et et
nous pensons que c'est vraiment le
moment en fait c'est le moment de
l'écologie cc on a des générations
futures là c'est plus possible quand on
peut pas continuer à aller dans le mur
comme ça et je pense que oui c'est c'est
finalement le meilleur des candidats que
nous avions au second tour yannick jadot
et est opposé à sandrine rousseau elle
s'est révélé aux yeux du grand public
lors de cette primaire elle incarne une
ligne beaucoup plus radical que monsieur
jadot qu'avez vous pensé de sa
candidature et de sa radicalité et ben
moi j'ai les jeux les vraiment
découverte mais c'est intéressant parce
que notre parti est composé de deux
justement ces deux composantes là c'est
à dire que on a toujours eu des
discussions sur il faut absolument il ya
une urgence climatique et
environnementale et sociale il faut
absolument qu'on comme maintenant nous
puissions agir et de l'autre côté nous a
tous nous avons toujours eu aussi une
volonté d'être un parti de gouvernement
de prendre de prendre le pouvoir pour
pouvoir porter allez allez les
politiques publiques qui sont urgentes à
mettre en oeuvre et du coup moi je
trouvais ça très très très intéressant
moi j'ai découvert sandrine que je ne
connaissais pas beaucoup j'ai trouvé
qu'elle disait des choses justes des
choses que que nous portons
dans dance party et est donc je suis
très contente de la collaboration qui
est qui est en train de se mettre en
place pour justement à faire en sorte
que ce soit à l'écologie politique qui
puisse enfin elles seraient majoritaires
dans ce pays alors pour gouverner
justement puisque vous en parlez vous
avez déjà quinze propositions sur la
table pour 2022 pour je cite une
république écologique et sociale et
selon vous donc pour commencer
l'écologie passera par l'investissement
le président de la république emmanuel
macron à planifier un plan
d'investissement de 30 milliards le qui
s'étalera jusqu'en 2030 vous vous
proposez avec europe ecologie les verts
d'investir 20 milliards par an dans
l'innovation et dans l'écologie lors
dans quels domaines faut-il investir
pour l'avenir aujourd'hui à bahia 2 2
les 20 milliards en fait sont sont là
pour réellement travaillé sur balles et
les les deux secteurs en fait qui
dégagent le plus de 2 de co2 à savoir la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments le
bâti donc la rénovation thermique des
matinées du bâtiment et en faisant de la
rénovation réellement de masse du bâti
ça a aussi un impact social très fort
puisque ça aide à soulager la facture la
facture énergétique sa règle la question
du co2 et sa règle également là là là et
la la la la diminution de l'usagé des
énergies des énergies fossiles et puis
l'autre l'autre point qui est qui est
aujourd'hui important c'est le transport
c'est la voiture diesel
ccc ce transport individuel qu'on a
aujourd'hui complètement développé en
france
je vais passer là trois jours à la
campagne dans le berry et je regardais
toutes ces maisons maintenant rénové qui
était en fait dans ce cas une gare en
fait on avait un maillage en france deux
gars juste incroyable et la voiture
individuelle à supprimer ces petites
lignes de train tout comme on a supprimé
le tramway que nous sommes en train
aujourd'hui de reconstruire et en fait
il faut aujourd'hui qu'on arrive à
trouver une mobilité qui soient
partagées et qu'ils ne soient plus
derrière la voiture individuelle et donc
et donc c'est vraiment les gars à neutre
à notre avis les deux secteurs sur
laquelle il faut en priorité est donc
vraiment mettre les moyens 20 milliards
sais pas c'est pas rien mais mettre les
moyens pour pouvoir justement faire en
sorte de muter de manière très urgent de
contrôle d'un chapeau claque des
investissements cela passe par des aides
publiques aussi que vous décrivez vous
déciderez de les conditionner pour les
entreprises il faudra que ces derniers
respectent des règles en matière de
climat de protection de l'environnement
alors comment ce que ça pourra
s'appliquer c'est la cristallisation
nous au moins eu le défend régulièrement
à la région ile de france c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on arrose les entreprises
et quand je dis on arrose c'est parce
que c'est des entreprises qui sont pas
en difficulté c'est vraiment des
entreprises de très grandes entreprises
que que l'on en aide or par exemple
on a donné récemment un million à
l'entreprise renault c'est en quoi je
pense qu'effectivement la construction
doit on doit travailler à sa transition
ce qui ne pose pas de souci sauf qu'il
n'ya aucun critère aucune
aucun échange on leur demande par
exemple de s'assurer que si on donne de
l'argent il n'y aura pas de licenciement
il n'y aura pas de délocalisation
ça c'est typiquement quelque chose qui
nous semblent nous indispensable tout
comme le l'innovation la recherche on
doit s'assurer que nous soyons bien sûr
sur de l'innovation qui ne va pas taper
sur sur des terres rares une fois une
fois pour toutes qui ne va pas engendrer
en fait débat dès les dysfonctionnements
plus grave pour pour la planète et donc
donc on a besoin aujourd'hui de
s'assurer que le développement
économique puisse se faire dans le
respect va d'aidé aux jeunes climatique
et sociaux autre mesure que vous
prendriez si europe ecologie les verts
arriveraient au pouvoir celle à 100 %
d'aliments bio dans les cantines et dans
les établissements publics alors comment
est ce que vous comptez mener cette
transition alimentaire cette transition
elle ne peut se faire bien évidemment
qu'avec qu'avec les agriculteurs
aujourd'hui l'on sait bien que ils sont
enfermés dans un modèle qui est qui qui
qui qui vaut pour eux enfin on voit bien
dans quel état aujourd'hui et
l'agriculture ce qui veut dire qu'il
faut réellement accompagner cette
transition on pense que 30 % des
montants de la pac doivent oeuvrer à 7 à
cette transition de la pac
commune européenne et donc et donc de
pouvoir réellement engagés cesser ses
actions et faire en sorte que la
production soit pour la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
nous avons une grande partie de notre de
notre production qui part qui part à
l'export or on voit bien typiquement
vous avez vu la baguette
augmente la baguette tout le monde parce
que y'a rien défaut de farine mais mais
en fait on a nous on est l'un des plus
grands producteurs de blé va il n'y a
pas de raison qu'en france on soit
obligé de payer plus cher la farine
alors qu aux produits localement de quoi
de quoi faire cesser ces dons qu'on a on
a aujourd'hui une une urgence à faire en
sorte que l'agriculture en france soit
en priorité pour de proximité locale et
puis faire en sorte surtout que on
diminue totalement et on supprime lusage
des des produits phytosanitaires pour
pouvoir faire effectivement du centre %
bio et pouvoir du coup alimenter nos
cantines publiques dans les écoles dans
les hôpitaux et les maisons de retraite
et tous ces autres toujours dans
l'agriculture vous souhaitez interdire
purement l'élevage en cage pour quelles
raisons mais mais tout simplement pour
des questions de bien-être animal enfin
on voit bien on a vu des images qui est
d'ailleurs les françaises et les
français ont découvert dans quel dans
quelles conditions sont élevés une
grande majorité d d d d d animaux que
nous que nous mangeons et que donc il
faut absolument que l'on arrête ça là
encore enfin c'est pas alors on pourra
toujours dire que les écolos veulent
revenir
au moyen-âge voilà à l'âge de pierre ou
se comportaient comme des amish en mai
mais on voit bien que c'est absolument
pas acceptable on peut pas ne pas élever
une poule dans dans une cage où elle
peut même pas se retourner on peut pas
faire ça avec avec un cochon peut enfin
c'est terrible en fait on se retrouve
finalement
enfin à réaliser que que que l'homme
enfin voila on n'a pas beaucoup respecté
les les êtres vivants sur cette planète
et je crois qu'on aura tout à gagner
tout et tout à gagner à faire en sorte
qu' on puisse effectivement continuer à
faire de l'élevage pour nous nourrir
parce que parce que nous sommes omnivore
par mois je je continue à penser que
voilà la polyculture relève l'âge a
toute sa place à tous sa place en france
mais pas dans n'importe quelle pas
n'importe quelles conditions est pas
encore pour pouvoir exporter à tout va
alors que finalement on pourrait très
bien avoir voilages
traités humainement sur la question de
la maltraitance animale l'assemblée
nationale a récemment voté une loi qui
interdit la présence d'animaux sauvages
dans les cirques elle interdit également
l'exploitation des dauphins et des
orques dans les delphinariums et enfin
il ne sera plus possible d'élever des
visons pour leurs fous rires c'est une
loi d'une grande importance pour la la
cause animale ou à ce qu'elle ne va pas
encore assez loin non elle va elle va
pas elle va pas assez loin parce que
justement on parle pas du tous de
l'élevage intensif skis et c'est ce qui
pose problème après c'est déjà un pas
enfin nous nous avez c'est vraiment des
combats là que nous menons depuis des
années et des années donc on va pas on
va pas se plaindre je pense qu'il faut
pas systématiquement tout critiquer mais
c'est vrai qu'on a on a ce sentiment
systématique de d'être dans le petit pas
de 2,2 de pouvoir
enfin faire en sorte que personne ne
soit fâché que donc on y va très
progressivement mais en fait je crois
qu'une loi devrait en tout cas porté les
objectifs finaux c'est-à-dire qu'elle
devrait porter un cadre et ensuite que
l'on puisse mettre en place un
calendrier et la question de de
l'élevage intensif aurait dû aurait dû
apparaître dans cette danse est là parmi
les 15 propositions pour une république
écologique et sociale vous promettez
aussi la zéro artificialisation des sols
c'était la revendication des
manifestants démarche des terres qui ont
lieu les 9 et 10 octobre dernier contre
des projets comme à grignon comme à
saclay alors pourquoi est-ce que vous
êtes contre ces nouveaux projets à mais
tout simplement parce que en fait ils
n'ont pas lieu d'être en fait on fait
croire aux franciliennes et les
franciliens que ce sont des projets
utiles gonesse il y avait donc ce projet
europa city qui maintenant a été
effectivement bloqué qui était le méga
centre commercial avec pistes de ski le
loisir etc
en nous faisant croire que ça allait
créer de l'emploi pour pour pour les
personnes qui habitent autour autour de
gonesse or on sait que les grands
centres commerciaux aujourd'hui détruit
plus d'emplois qu'il n'en crée
réellement et quant à l'impact
climatique une piste de ski sous
d'hommes enfin voila je pense que c'est
pas la peine de que je m'étale là-dessus
grignon grillon c'est je trouve encore
totalement scandaleux on a un domaine un
patrimoine incroyable vraiment sûr sûr
sûr grillon qui n'est pas simplement du
patrimoine historique bâti mais c'est
aussi un patrimoine naturel qui est qui
est mondialement connu c'est vraiment le
berceau de l'agronomie en france est le
seul projet qui a choisi l'état soutenu
par la région ile de france au travers
de sa scène est soutenu par par le
département quoi qu'on en dise
département des yvelines c'est de vendre
du bâti pour aller faire du logement du
logement de
déficient de défiscalisation c'est à
dire qu'on va vendre des baux happart
qui sont situés dans un magnifique cadre
pour pouvoir faire de la défiscalisation
fois et face à ça il y a un projet
incroyable porté par les élèves les
anciens d'agroparistech porté par l'inra
qui vise réellement à créer un centre
dédié à l'environnement à l'alimentation
dans la continuité de ce qui a toujours
été ce ce site est donc faisons faisons
preuve est à la fois de d'intelligence
collective c'est à dire assurons nous
que les projets qui sont porter soit
soutenue et par les élus locaux et par
les habitants et par les usagers eux
mêmes de ces deux ce2 ce2 de ce
patrimoine plutôt que d'aller chercher
le promoteur immobilier qui comme
d'habitude va voilà profiter profitez en
fait de ce bâti pour pour faire de la
spéculation foncière faire du produit de
défiscalisation et engranger
voilà des intérêts privés alors qu'il ya
vraiment un site remarquable et écoutons
les élus locaux enfin je crois que là
vraiment sûr sur grignon en particulier
je crois que l'état a vraiment fait
faillite aux riches et que la
concertation et la démocratie est née
n'est manifestement pas un sujet pour
eux pour le pouvoir d'achat vous
souhaitez mettre en place ce que l'on
pourrait appeler une tva écologique elle
serait donc abaissé en fonction des
produits et de leur impact sur leur
environnement par exemple pour les
produits blu bio pardon vous mettriez la
tva à zéro pour cent absolument en fait
on a on a la possibilité de pouvoir
moduler une tva en fonction de l'impact
énergétique climatique des des produits
ce qui permettrait de valoriser en fait
les les produits les plus les plus
vertueux et c'est comme ça que au fur et
à mesure on arrivera effectivement
atteindre tous les objectifs que nous
nous sommes que nous nous sommes fixés
en fait il faut accompagner vous savez y
aller
les françaises et les français en fait
sont sur les premiers à faire beaucoup
d'efforts et font des gestes des gestes
écologiques mais si l'état lui même si
la puissance publique n'accompagne pas
ses gestes et bien en fait voilà on
arrivera on n'arrivera à rien et donc
donc je pense que cette cette question
que teva
variable permettra d'accompagner en
gardant en fait un des des ressources
permettra d'accompagner cette transition
nous avons déjà reçu dans les politiques
des membres du ps de l'alfi ils se sont
montrés plutôt favorables à une union de
la gauche pour les présidentielles vous
quelle est votre position est ce que
c'est possible là aujourd'hui pour être
tout à fait honnête et très sincère je
pense que ça va être très ça va être
très compliqué parce qu'on a des fortes
personnalités
que ce soit anne hidalgo qui d'ailleurs
a dit qu'elle qu'elle refuserait de
rejoindre yannick jadot et qu'elle
continuerait la bataille jean luc
mélenchon qui veut aussi elle est allée
jusqu'au bout donc ce serait ce serait
mentir de dire qu'aujourd'hui il est
encore possible de pouvoir se rassembler
où on l'a fait au second tour des
régionales jeunes au niveau look comme
ça ça fonctionne
pas tant de la rue même nom pas tant que
ça au niveau des régionales pas il faut
se le dire sinon s'ils savaient vraiment
marché aujourd'hui on serait au serait à
la tête de la région et on rendrait
l'union a marché mais le résultat ça n'a
pas convaincu les foules yen et les
franciliens en fait on voit bien que
nous portons des valeurs de gauche ça
n'a aucun aucun sujet là dessus mais je
crois que le projet que nous portons
chacun à différemment ne ne porte pas
les mêmes les mêmes priorités
yannick jadot a fait montre lors des
dernières élections présidentielles
d'une capacité à s'effacer pour que
justement la gauche puisse remporter ce
c'est ces élections ça n'a pas
fonctionné du tout nous aujourd'hui nous
pensons que réellement c'est l'écologie
politique qui peut rassembler donc donc
donc moi je suis de celles qu'ils chic
yannick jadot doit aussi aller jusqu'au
bout nous en nous et face à la dernière
fois nous n'avons pas eu de
parlementaires nous n'avons pas
parlementaire à l'assemblée nationale
c'est à dire que nous pouvons même pas
influé sur les lois alors que nous
sommes les écologistes et que nous avons
vraiment le sentiment que c'est sur ces
sujets que nous devons avancer eh bien
on veut pas on veut pas revivre ça on
veut pas revivre ça on comprend que les
autres partis ne veulent pas non plus se
retrouver démunis ce qu'est ce qui est
ce qui nous semble légitime mais nous
pensons réellement que nous sommes ceux
qui sont le plus à même à porter les
idées de l'écologie ça fait ça fait 40
ans que nous portons ces sujets ça fait
quarante ans qu'on nous savons
exactement vers où il faut aller et et
je crois que en tout cas voilà c'est en
tout cas passer une seconde fois nous ne
laisserons pas passer à ce tour parce
qu'il ya urgence climatique questions
régionales pour finir cette émission sur
le projet eole qui doit prolonger le rer
e à l'ouest jusqu'à mantes vous dénoncez
vous le surcoût de ce projet et vous
demander des comptes à valérie pécresse
absolument nous demandons à nous
demandons des comptes des ados qu'un
dérapage de 1 milliard sept sur sur la
mise en oeuvre des hommes nous avons
appris il y a trois jours que les rer
angie donc nouvelle génération qui sont
qui devait doté à cette ligne devait
être très bien évidemment en
l'occurrence pour 2023 ce sera pour 2025
ceci dit je pense que hall qui était
prévu pour 2024 voilà on va prendre va
prendre du retard parce que nous n'avons
pas encore aujourd'hui les nouveaux les
nouveaux financements nous avons demandé
à ce qu'une une mission d'information et
d'évaluation soit mise en place valérie
pécresse va le mettre à l'ordre du jour
du mois de novembre
et j'espère qu'elle n'acceptera à ce que
nous puissions avoir toutes les
informations sur sur ce dérapage un
milliard c'est tu sais pas c'est pas
rien c'est pas normal que on soit
aujourd'hui façades et des grandes
entreprises qui ne respectent pas leur
parole on fait des appels d'offres des
marchés
justement pour pour faire des choix de
d'entreprise et au final on voit bien
que lorsque nous sommes sur des très
grands projets et bien en fait les
entreprises n'arrivent pas à n'arrive
pas à suivre alors il ya ulcos vie dont
je n'ai pas de soucis sur
du retard pouvait être pouvait être pris
mais à ce stade un tel dérapage n'est
pas n'est pas acceptable et donc il faut
savoir qui est responsable de ces de ces
dérapages et comment faire une bonne
fois pour toutes pour arrêter et éviter
à ce que ça puisse se reproduire merci
beaucoup ghislaine séné d'être venu dans
l'hebdo politique sur radio sensations
mais je vous en prie merci à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes la présidente du
pôle écologiste à la région ile de
france nous on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
l'hebdo politique en attendant très
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]
l'hebdo politique